boo like kev here we got kenny money in
the building the new album is out yup go
watch our interview
separate youtube video the only
interview you've ever done yeah i just
found this out and now we're about to
get to the rapping man go go run it up
time is money right time is money
[Music]
[__] ain't stopping [__] long as i'm
breathing i'm gonna get these chills
come on you little [__] know how i
live i bought some more ice when they
tell me to chill cover nineteen i got
too many boogers my nick and my wreaths
and my fingers they eat the whole time i
been living like i got a deal i know a
few ways i can make me a meal i know a
few ways i can make your [__] calm
don't make me come laying your [__]
like a crew yeah yeah i tried [__] with
a whole lot of skills about playing
money making buffalo bills real estate
money got a whole lot of tools got a lot
of loot screws and we still do drills
straight out the streets i ain't scared
of no fear straight up i still put a
hole in some heels i do a hell but to
give me a bankroll for what they
thinking is hear what it is he did what
it is when i have drank i had to go save
some like queer when i had no cash in my
pockets i had to get hacked if i did
everything but still i used to be saying
that look in my grill i'm smiling beat
diamonds these are these still i spent
half a ticket last year but this year
i'ma blow a little more showed him on
for real
[__] for real for real i ain't been the
site so my brother got killed my
diamonds real clear but my head had been
cleared i'm trying to see somebody draw
like a teal i ain't speaking no wax i
ain't using my lils just know it's all
good put the gang on my reel for you
we're gonna pop it for my [__] flip got
two pieces on me and my jack and my jeep
[Music]
go watch the interview go get the album
go run it up time is money out now let's
go shout out lrg let's get it hey i know
you just watched the crazy freestyle
appreciate you watching make sure you
subscribe and make sure
you show some love to our folks at lrg
clothing man listen
i've been [__] with lrg since i was
in high school and they are still doing
their [__] thing all right and i got
something special for you 30 off
your next order at lrg all you got to do
is use the keyword and by keyword i mean
promo code use the promo code kev30
that's
kev30 we're gonna put the website right
there you see it right there
l dash r
g dot com all right we'll put the
website right there cook put the website
right there
save you 30 off one more time use that
promo code kev 30 on lrg's website for
your chance well not your chance you'll
actually get 30 off it's not like it's a
[__] contest just use the code and
you got it all right shout out to lrg